Speaker 1: Nikki Haley appeared on
Neil CAVUTO, Fox News show yesterday.
She tried to explain her plan to raise
the Social Security retirement age,
and that ended up being an insane word salad
that made no sense. She really is struggling
to explain her policies. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Governor, then how would you dress
when you talked about changing the retirement
security? What were you talking about?
Speaker 8: So if we're talking about entitlement
reform, the first thing we do is, look,
I have parents in my eight in their eighties.
We take care of them. I don't want anything to
hurt the seniors or anyone that's getting ready
to retire. But I have kids in their twenties.
Those are the ones that need to go and know that
things are going to be change. So what you would
do is for those in their twenties coming into the
system, we would change the retirement age so that
it matches life expectancy. The second thing
we would do is we would limit benefits for the
wealthy. That then you go further instead of to.
Speaker 1: Understand that benefits are already
limited for the wealthy and it has nothing to
do with inflation. Like this is just a mishmash
that reflects a total lack of understanding and
lack of thinking about what the hell is going on.
Speaker 8: Living increases do increases based
on inflation. That's something Republicans and
Democrats would agree with. And then more than
that. Expand Medicare Advantage plan so that we
have more competition and we run the costs down.
Speaker 1: Now, that actually has nothing to
do with Social Security. Nothing.
Speaker 8: That's what entitlement
reform will look like. That's how you go and make
it sustainable. And that's also how you bring down
the cost of what we're seeing right now.
Speaker 2: So when you're talking about
adjusting the ages, depending on, you know, kids
in their twenties and obviously that they can
come into the program later, they might have
other options. What are you telling those in
their sixties now or in their fifties now? At
what point would a president, Nikki Haley say,
All right, we're bringing you in a little later.
Speaker 8: You keep your promises to those that
weren't that we've made, promises to those
that have invested in should keep what they
have. We shouldn't in any way jeopardize
those that are already expecting something.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but the problem is when she
talks about people in their twenties will get
lower benefits. Most people in their twenties have
also started to pay it. So really, if you wanted
to do this fairly, you would say we're going to
raise the retirement age for people who have not
yet started to pay in. That would really be the,
quote, fair way to do it under this paradigm.
Speaker 8: It's about the
new group coming in. So what.
Speaker 2: I'm sorry, what is new.
Speaker 8: That they're not going.
Speaker 2: To I'm sorry. What's the new group?
Is it. Are you telling those 50 and over you're
safe. The 50 and under your. I just use that
arbitrary number. What are you saying as a group
that what you're saying that's going to change?
Speaker 8: It's the new ones coming in. It's those
in their twenties that are coming in.
Speaker 1: But remember,
people in their twenties, particularly if they
had jobs in high school or during college,
they've already started paying in with the belief
that their benefits are going to be based on the
current system. So it doesn't really work.
Speaker 8: You're coming to them and you're
saying the game has changed. We're going to
do this completely differently. That's how
you go and you focus on it. We've got to start
doing things like that. But more than that,
I mean, we have to look at the fact that
there is a spending problem in D.C..
Speaker 1: And that's totally unrelated because
that's actually a separate issue from the way
that Social Security is funded. And they love to
do that and go, well, we've got debt. Okay. Right.
But like the Social Security system has its own
tax collection system and its own benefit system,
and the funds are invested in a particular
way. What does our general that have to do
with that? It really doesn't have much to do
with it unless they wanted to argue, Well,
inflation in general devalues Social Security
benefits, but they're indexed to inflation,
at least in theory. So Nikki Haley is not
exactly showing a deep understanding of
this. She's talking about limiting benefits for
wealthy people. Their benefits are already limited
in part to limited by the fact that we only tax
the first 100 and whatever thousand of income.
And that is where the limitation
comes from. And then she's talking
about Medicare Advantage and whatever else.
I don't think she really understands what's
going on. That's my opinion based on this
response. You let me know if you disagree.